good morning morning everyone um I hope
you have your winter coats here it was
57 degrees in this room when I arrived
and um if you want to talk in order to
raise the temperature that would be okay
with me um I'd like to call to order um
the Judiciary subcommittee that's
looking at Senate Bill 255 and House
Bill 34
um the bills are of the two bills and
I'm going to begin with the house bill
which is House Bill
314 um relative to the expectation of
privacy in the collection and use of
personal
information um my plan unless my uh
colleagues disagree would be to be Begin
by taking stock from the members of
where we are and then with everyone's um
agreement I would uh like to turn to
some of the people who have uh done us
the courtesy of of coming to share their
views with us to help us um figure out
where we're going to go from here so if
that approach is okay I'd like like to
begin um and
uh I guess I would begin by asking
um chairman Lynn if he would like to
share with us where he is at the moment
on this
issue thank you madam chair
um so I I guess what I would say where I
am is I'm
conflicted um
as as I I think I've mentioned before I
um and I know we want to focus on 314
for now but I I guess what I would say
is because I think it has some
implications for that I do support
255 with the with the a couple of
amendments that that I think I propose
and maybe some others proposed and and
and the importance of that is I think
that it's kind of important to make sure
that 34 if 255 were to pass to make sure
that 14 kind of gels with it and so um I
had proposed an
amendment to
314 um which I I think I sent to
everyone on this
subcommittee um that
basically um did away with with what I
thought was one of the points of
contention um about the language in in
314 that purports to create a reasonable
expectation of
privacy um in certain
information um and as I think I said I
my basic thought
was if we're just going to limit this to
if the
only if the reach of this statute is
going to be limited to the
government we can simply we could simply
say the government shall not do what the
what the what 314 says they can't do um
and if they do there would be um some
liability um so that was kind of my
Approach I have to say that that
representative Earth and and former
representative
Kirk uh presented an alternative
proposal which um
uh moved the ball I think on to address
some of the concerns that I had for
example one thing that it did which I
think was really important is it
although it would allow a private right
of
action um both
against the government a government
actor and a private actor that is
subject to
314 it it um limits the private action
only to actual damage as as opposed to a
sort of penalty that would apply if
there was a violation whether there were
any actual damages or not um that's a I
think that's a big step that you know
that makes a difference to me I'm
still I'm still not convinced that we
should have a private action
against against um entities other than
government entities um so that that's
kind of where where I am representative
Alexander thank you madam chair um
representative
Lynn in your um vast experience how
would you measure so I know
that how would you measure actual
damages com of like sharing somebody's
information like how would how would you
consider calculating that if you were
awarding a penalty sure well you know
that I mean that's a very good question
I mean I think one of the reasons that I
think it should be limited to actual
damages is my sense is that in the V
vast majority of cases even if there's
been some violation of you know of the
right to privacy as created by
34 there probably would not be any real
damages in other words you know would
somebody
say Okay so the so uh uh one of the
people one of the entities that's
covered by
314 um and is not supposed to sell
information let's say to a third party
so they sell the information and you get
in your email you know uh uh buy you
know buy a BMW or buy some some kind of
car okay you may be annoyed I'm not in
the market for BMW but have you really
been harmed in some way um so I I guess
I say that I think in most cases there
isn't likely to be much harm but I also
concede that there could be some cases
in which there would be you know real
tremendous harm and uh somebody and I
suppose somebody you know somebody was
injured or even killed bu because some
information that was disclosed that
shouldn't have been and there of course
I you know the person should be able to
recover damages I don't have any problem
with that and and I'm I'm inclined to
agree with you in that way that getting
rid of the penalty and putting in actual
damages I think will go a long way and
um limiting it to government actors is
in my opinion what we should be doing so
thank you Bob okay representative
L uh representative Devine
I tend to think a little bit otherwise I
think other like maybe corporations or
small small even smaller companies might
be taking your information say images
video images and then using them without
your express permission because you
signed off unwi unwittingly signed off
and accepted some sort of terms and
agreements that you didn't realize that
they could in the future use your image
for something and I I don't think think
that's necessarily right if people are
unaware of that when they um accept any
sort of terms and conditions I think
their privacy is violated and then could
be used in another another way and
that's not just government that's small
businesses corporations all that so that
would be my
concern representative
T yeah and and I will say you know I
know there was a couple of different
versions of amendments floating around
so hope
there there was one uh Mr chairman uh
from you and and and representative
Earth I think was the the last version
that that I received so hopefully I'm
speaking to the one that you sort of
were were most
uh proposing um I like the idea that we
took out the the private the the the
individual you know that limited it to
government only because I think there
was some sentiment that those two things
were sort of mismatched in the first
bill and and 255 seems to cover some of
that some of some of that ground um and
I I did go through and look at all the
exclusions that sort of have been added
to that version and it seemed like we
covered most of the concerns that I
think I heard raised during during the
original testimony um on the bill I have
a couple of uh specific thoughts about
that language um but I I know that we're
not really into that meat of it yet I
just in general I thought that was that
was a proposal that I thought moved it
Forward um
if I'm referencing the right the right
version which I think was sent a couple
days
ago yeah that was that was
representative uh uh F's and and uh rep
repres former representative Kirk's uh
Amendment that's the one that would
allow an action against both the private
private entities and um uh and
government
entities I have a
problem and um I need your help
I
thought that the
main
focus
of this bill
was to be the private
sector
not the
government buy and
large in the
Hampshire
um the Hampshire does pretty well in
terms
of the
government recognizing the importance of
privacy they're always outliers we know
that
but it's bad business to shape
legislation around around an
outlier um or an
exception and I think the problem is not
the government and although I have
trouble understanding it all and I'm
very clear about that that that I have
trouble um there are exceptions
exemptions I guess is a better word
already in the the legislation that I
believe a lot of the government agencies
have agreed to so I I see the
problem
as focusing on the private sector not
the government sector so tell me where
I'm
wrong well you know one I mean one thing
that I and I guess maybe I'd like to
hear from if if either representative F
or representative Kirk could address
this but one of the things that went
went that um that I think is would be an
issue is 255
as it's currently drafted does not allow
for a private right of action but it
does allow for the Attorney General to
bring an action and my my understanding
is that if 255 were to
pass the I think this is true and that's
is what I asked to correct me if I'm
wrong I think that it would
cover all of the entities that are
covered in 314 it ALS also covers more
entities than that but it but it
encompasses I think all of the entities
that are covered by
so
there I guess what I'm saying is there
would be a remedy under 255 for privacy
violations in the by Private Industry it
would Lim it would be limited to the
attorney general bringing bringing the
remedy but there would be a remedy I I
hear you Mr chair but these are two
separate
bills and we
cannot pass or support one bill with the
expectation that the other bill is also
going to pass in exactly the form that
we would like it to because I know this
will come as a surprise but sometimes
things don't actually happen exactly as
we would like them to not all always but
sometimes if everyone else is
comfortable um uh chairman Lynn has
mention the names of Representative F
and former representative Kirk is it
okay with the committee if we hear from
them at this point or would you like us
to
continue I think that if you two would
mind well I would I'm asking both of you
if you would like one or the other
um I I know that I need help frequently
in dealing with uh former representative
Kirk which is why I thought that perhaps
representative Earth should
come so would you
would thank you very much you know would
would you make sure
that that he treats me
respectfully thank
you
fortunately representative Kirk knew I
was joking so I don't have to
apologize uh good morning Madam chairman
good morning to members of the committee
for the record I'm Neil Kirk former
representative I live in we and I'm
representing myself uh
today
um there is a relationship between
255 and U
um
314 is designed primarily to cover the
private
sector there is very little evidence as
the chairman suggested that we have a
problem with New Hampshire state
government abusing the opportunities
available to it to invade people's
privacy with regulatory agencies seeking
information about individuals that they
shouldn't have that's unnecessary to
their function
indeed uh representative F and I worked
extensively with various agencies to
carve out for them in
314 the ability to continue business as
usual so if you take away the private
sector from
314 as a practical matter the only
impact of 314 will be on the state
police law enforcement law enforcement
would have to get in the original B
a Judicial Court warrant based on
probable cause but in various amendments
simply an administrative subpoena from
the local County attorney or somebody
like that to get information from the
telephone company or the utility or the
internet service provider that they want
in a particular case all of the other
actions of state government would
continue as before because as I say
representative and F and I met with them
and we we created exemption so that they
could continue work because there was
basically no point in having this bill
since they were not violating its
Provisions so the main thrust of
314 is on the private sector and it's
significantly
different from um 255 255 covers the
Waterfront in terms of the types of
businesses involved but 314 only applies
to a small subset of the private sector
internet service providers um provider
telephone companies Utilities in other
words providers of goods and
services information Goods I'm sorry
information not Goods information not
Goods so to the extent that 255 covers
companies that sell Goods like Amazon
Amazon is not covered by
314 because it doesn't sell a service it
sells
Goods so 3 14 was designed to deal with
the United States Supreme Court decision
of some years ago saying that you have
no expectation of privacy when you
provide personal information to a
third-party provider of information and
services and I thought for the people of
New Hampshire that didn't make
sense we expect that when we give
information to a telephone company or an
internet service provider to get that
service that the reason for giving them
the information is to give us the
service not to give them an opportunity
to use that information for other
purposes or to take the information they
get from their our use of their service
and use it for their purposes so for
example I don't want the telephone
company to be able to tell anyone that
I've made calls to certain let's say
psychological
providers I don't want the my internet
service provider to detail my use of the
internet and the various sites that I
visit and sell that or give that or use
that for some other purpose that's not
why I signed up for those services and
so 314 is designed to say to these
Internet to the service providers to the
providers third party providers of
information and services that the only
thing they can do with our information
is to give it is to use it to provide
the service they're contracted for and
for no other purpose unless we give them
consent and that's one of the um that
that's the
impetus that drove uh 314 and I think is
reflected in all of the other amendments
that you've seen with the exception of
the amendment from that you have seen
from techet and perhaps some others that
that have been floating around um
frankly if you take the private sector
out of 314 if that's your opinion that
you don't want to do anything and and
and allow the private service providers
and information providers to continue
using their information information a
personal information in the way they
have then you should kill the bill I
hate to say that about one of my babies
but there's no point in subjecting um
government agencies who are not misusing
this
information um to any strictures when
it's unnecessary so
um it's it's not often that I come in
and say if you're going to amend the
bill kill it but in this case I don't
want to impose restrictions on law
enforcement which I have no evidence to
think is abusing it but if you don't if
you pass the bill with taking out the
private sector that's the only part of
state government and local governments
that will be affected by the
bill as a practical
matter um thank you could I ask you a
question I can ask will you answer a
question
um should any
state be in the business is doing this
is this not better handled um in um at
the national level if we actually happen
to have a n a functioning National
Congress uh it would be very nice if
Congress were to deal with these privacy
issues and indeed on 255 Microsoft has
said they've tried
unsuccessfully to have a national Bill
and they've been they they can't do it
all of us would prefer a good solid
National bill as opposed to individual
State efforts but the federal government
even when it's functioning cannot come
to grips with this in a way that results
in legislation and so various States
from California to Connecticut and New
Hampshire on their own are trying to
deal with this and obviously the
industry all Industries have a problem
with this approach because now they have
to deal with 50 different sets of rules
rather than than one set and so as
techet and others are doing they're
trying and Microsoft is doing in 255
they're trying to get uniformity at the
state level and oppose anything that
does not promote
uniformity um I hope that answers your
question there's one other comment that
I wanted to make that I forgot to
representative Lynn said before that 255
would cover uh a lot of the ground for
the private sector I'd point out that
255 only applies to large companies you
have to have a 100,000 users in New
Hampshire so all small businesses that
might be covered smaller businesses that
might be covered by 314 are not
covered by 255 there's a huge group of
people that would be covered by the one
bill private sector folks that would be
covered by the one bill but not by the
other thank you does anyone have any
questions representative deine has a
question
no okay now I'm on okay I was wondering
if you could give um an example of how
this bill might
affect um a company that was you know
maybe doing the wrong things with your
information just another example so we
as a panel can really understand a live
example of how that might happen is that
could you do that um let's say that uh
um you're an internet service
provider and um you notice that I'm
visiting all sorts of Hemlock type
sites because I'm planning on committing
suicide presumably or at least that's
one and by the way I am not uh that's
one inference that you could draw you
don't have to say that representative
Kirk because we respect your
privacy thank you madam chairman I
appreciate that um
so the um the internet service provider
could use this information for example
um by contacting a psychologists or
psychiatrists and giving them my name as
well as other people these are a group
of people who have visited various sites
you might be interested in contacting
them unlikely that they would but that
kind of thing can happen um if I were to
visit sites that indicated I was uh
trying to find some explosives that kind
of information uh could be used by the
internet service provider
hopefully ways that don't harm me
um there are situations where um a
telephone company for
example might know where my phone is at
all times and presumably where my phone
is I am but that's not always the case
um and they could take that information
and they could um provide that
to anybody who was interested in
learning locations usually companies
that are selling goods and services so
if I for example were went from Lowe's
to Home Depot and to Tractor Supply um
that information might be very important
to companies that sell the kinds of
goods those companies sell and they
might then solicit me with advertising
or things like that I'm not trying to
take extreme examples here because we we
know that they could anyone can abuse
the system um but the question is for me
again um if I run my personal life by
using the internet and the telephone and
utility electricity which tells where I
am by the bases by uh some of these new
smart meters which can tell how much
electricity used by the hour then
um I I feel less comfortable knowing
that so much of information about me is
is is in the hands of other people and I
don't know what they're using
for um perhaps representative Earth has
some examples that would better answer
your question I didn't think I did a
particularly um helpful job
but I'll I'll just add to that I my my
concern is um you know where the say the
internet we have all this information
that is live on our phones and we have
um we have a generation of people that
know the difference between before we
had phones and the computers the way we
do and then we have the
generation now that is moving forward
that doesn't that are moving forward
that don't understand the differences of
maybe ethical um practices in business
and my concern is when you're on your
phone and and you're opting in or you're
accepting any sort of terms and
conditions and you're you're letting
them take your information and you don't
really know what that is until maybe you
get home and you can actually read the
40 pages of terms and conditions that
maybe some small company might have or a
private um company might have and to me
that there's a problem there because
sometimes there are companies that will
be ethical about it and then there
there's other ones that won't and
they'll just scrape that information
save it they might go back they might
find something else about I just think
there could be a longterm
effect if we don't do anything now so
I'm my wondering is what kind of
examples that can give the panel to get
maybe a bill like this passed so you can
see the long-term ramifications of what
having nothing in place for citizens of
New Hampshire can um have some sort sort
of action taken against companies small
smaller businesses not even just um say
a phone company I'm I'm just thinking
there's all these apps that are just
they're they're collecting so much
information from just from the phone and
and younger people are are kind of
unaware I think of the ramifications of
that and I think it's important to have
something like this thank you for that
question
um let me first say that that an
amendment that I've drawn up uh dated
August
29th um deals with the problem that you
mentioned about this kind of usage
buried in a conditions kind of thing
that nobody reads and we all accept
because it would preclude companies from
uh allowing from um doing that it would
ban the company from having me wave the
provisions of this protection so this
protection would be
guaranteed
um when you grow up and you're used to
something it's hard to change you have
the before and after your children and
my children probably may do depending on
our ages but they're but our
grandchildren certainly do not and will
not um and it's up to us I think to make
the decision that they should have that
choice that it is
important um and we should do something
about it which is the reason for passing
314 I'd only point out that
um well let me leave it
that
um uh representative Kirk Could you
um help the um subcommittee by pointing
have you distributed this amendment
dated August 29th to everyone I have not
but I have copies if if could you could
you share those now and then um point
out to
um I mean as long as long as
you're up now this would be a good time
I
have thank you
um to highlight those particular points
that you and and and uh representative F
would like us to be aware of and do you
have copies for people I have a few
extra copies which I've left there
thank sorry can put that with
your
um are you asking me to explain yes I'm
asking you to explain the change es that
you are proposing to this
subcommittee that address the concerns
that we've been talking
about I'd be glad to do
that I thought you might
be
um this amendment continues the original
U coverage of the bill it covers both
the private sector you put the
microphone closer to you thank you this
bill covers as the original bill does
both the private and the public sector
so that is is U perhaps the most
significant thing that folks need to
know um it retains the car outs for
state agencies that was in the original
bill in other words this bill will allow
state agencies to continue to function
as they did before and as I said um they
know they're aware of this language
we've met with them and they have no
problems with it at least they didn't
as recently as
June um this bill adopts um the position
that representative Lynn uh wanted with
respect to law enforcement subpoenas
instead of judicial subpoenas they are
uh administrative subpoenas and that
makes it much easier for law enforcement
to get access to this this information
and where do we find that oh
[Music]
um that
is
um page two line
10 on sorry line 11 yeah okay I see
thank you signed by a judge and based on
probable cause and that's been deleted
okay um
thirdly it adds a def a definition of
available to the public which was
intended to satisfy the municipal
association's um
concerns and that would be on page one L
page one lines 6 through n right
okay
um fourthly it deals with House Bill
255 on page two lines 1 and two you mean
Senate bill Senate sorry Senate Bill
255 um unless such providers are
specifically Exempted from this chapter
they are not and
therefore
255 the the private sector companies
would be covered by both 255 and
314 and the stricter of those two would
obviously apply so
um this still would cover all of the
smaller businesses that are not covered
by
255 and the larger businesses that are
covered by 255 would have to meet both
the provisions of 255 and 314 to the
extent there's any conflict um and they
would be bound by both of
them fifth this protects
consumers uh um by precluding
third-party providers of information and
services from waving the Bill's
Provisions as a condition of doing
business with them page this is on page
two lines 32 and
33 no third- party provider of
information and services may require a
waiver from the provisions of this
chapter as a condition for an individual
to do business with it this doesn't mean
that they can't ask for a waiver they
can and an individual could do it but
but if an individual
declined the business could not say
sorry we're not going to serve
you
and
fifthly it adopts representative Lynn's
position with respect to damages and you
heard him talk about that before that's
on page three lines 1 through
three which basically say uh you can sue
and collect damages but only if you can
demonstrate there are damages there's no
$1,000 penalty or $100 penalty for
violation of the bill um I share
representative Lyn's concern that we
don't want to create a situation where
we have unnecessary class action
lawsuits and this provision um goes a
long way to prevent that those are the
changes that this amendment makes from
the original
Bill thank you do you have anything you
want to add
representative yeah yes not specifically
to the individual changes but more
broadly
so I want to emphasize that this is
about informational
privacy and in our lifetimes certainly
in mine um information has
become
data and it's very easily propagated at
no cost or very low cost um it's very
easy to spread it around the world and
communicate it with at very low or no
cost we as you're all aware asked a
constitutional amendment a few years ago
by overwhelming majorities and I think U
we've been working uh representative
Kirk and I have been working on this
bill for five years now and I think in
that time one of the things I've learned
and probably this committee has as well
since they've seen the bill so many
times is it's not clear exactly what
that constitutional right entails
and I would argue that one of the
reasons it passed with such an
overwhelming majority by our voters keep
that in mind these are the people that
put us here is that there is a concern
about this kind of privacy to um
Representatives point about the the the
U all the data that's collected by
Facebook and that sort of thing but
remember that this doesn't protect you
from things you publish so if you're
putting it out there on Facebook or
whatever then that's on you you're
giving it away it's that it's that
information that you don't really even
think about that you're giving away when
you work with big
corporations and with the government and
i' also point out that there's there's
been concern on the part of the
government about what they can do
there's obviously concern from industry
about what they um can do but both of
those entities can afford to defend
themselves most people are not in a
situation where they can afford to
defend themselves and it's those those
people it's the vote our voters that's
who we're looking to protect here from
informational privacy which is
essentially invisible to all of us it
just flies around as little bits on
wires and we have no clue um about it
and this really just starts to delineate
where businesses and government need to
be careful about what they do with
information that they collect as a
byproduct of the services that they're
providing
thank you very much for that
um it's my am I correct that you are
clearly
separating the whole area of social
media because there it is the
principal who
is spreading the
information yes with the exclusion that
the representative pointed out here that
companies can't hide a waver to give
away information that is personal not
not not that you've publicly put out
there but you've given to them as a
result or just in order to get the
service so to the extent that they're
not allowed to force you to wave that if
you're posting on Facebook or on Twitter
or all the other places you can post
stuff then you're putting that
information out there and this is very
clear the information that you put into
the public domain and that's very well
defined um you know that that's on you
you're you're making that available to
anybody who wants to see
it and use it for M purposes
representative Alexander has a question
thank you madam chair thank you for
hopefully taking my question um the the
coercion of the waiver is where my
question is so um say I open up the Uber
app and I want a Uber downtown
Manchester from gtown I want to go to
the
bars my location is is available to Uber
and I might say in that situation no I
don't want to share my information but
what's stopping a company from every
single time I opening up the Uber app
for them to ask like I see there's no
language in here for them to
say it like once I say no once like
there's nothing saying they can't put
the waiver pop it up on my phone again
so every single time I'm using Uber
every single time I'm using Facebook
Twitter like they're going to ask and
once I say yes once then my information
sharable so I guess how do how does this
address that well I would hope you'd
have your width well enough about you at
any given time that you'd always say no
I mean I I guess there's really no way
to I'm just I'm just thinking I'm not
part of the Gen Z generation but I'm
very very close and I will tell you that
they will accept it once just to get it
out of the way and then the information
is public so that's that's my only
concern with that sort of language there
well I guess they leave it to the
Judgment of the committee I mean
certainly you could change the wording
there to say that once you said no no
means
no that's an interesting
concept thank you for that
representative
um are you satisfied with
that any other
questions so you know I guess
representative Lynn has a question thank
you so with regard to
um section H3 of your proposed amendment
on page three this chapter shall not be
construed to create a cause of action
against a non-governmental a
non-government entity for providing
information to a government entity and I
guess my question there is so
if I mean does that mean that if if the
phone
company um gets information that it
shouldn't
have and it provides
it if it provides it to anybody any any
other third party presumably the phone
company would be liable under this but
if it provides it to the
government even if it obtained it
illegally that the it's it's
somehow it it's shielded from liability
for that which might be the where did
could you tell me understand you know
you're the lawyer I'm not and you're the
judge I'm not um you say acquire
illegally really
um problem I guess I'm concerned about
what they're acquiring legally right
right am I missing the point no but
words I think I should say Judge Lynn
for that question yeah no I'm what I'm
really just saying is have we
created
if if they acquire some information in
violation of the other provisions of the
statute of the
bill and then provide that to the
government they are sort of this seems
to say they're exempt from liability and
I'm guess I'm wondering why why is that
if it's if it falls within one of the
exceptions I can completely understand
then because it's then not illegal but
if it's if it
doesn't so first of all this presumes
all the information that the companies
have is acquired legally that that's
we're not talking about illegally
obtained information this is what
they've what they've obtained in the
course of doing their business so it's
it's it's legal so we got to start
there the second point is the this was
put in for businesses because they're
very concerned that the government who
has the right
to demand information with warrants or
whatever that they might corporations
might get themselves in trouble by
providing information legally that they
control that the government is legally
requesting but they would be somehow
subject to something for doing that and
the point of this is to say no the
government is legally requesting
information that the companies legally
hold then they are not going to be
subject to the company is not going to
be subject to penalty for that okay I I
I guess I I understand your explanation
I guess the only thing you in you've
added the word legally a couple of times
in your and it and my concern is that H3
doesn't say that the word legally is not
in there well so that's let's go back to
I mean it change the wording to suit you
of course because you know better than I
do that outside of things but going back
to the very beginning with the
definitions about what things are in
there I mean it's pretty clear what kind
of information we're talking about right
this this is
not you know if the corporations hold
information illegally isn't Don't They
isn't that already a crime putting
inside this
bill oh no no I mean it may be depending
depending on what what what kind of
information it is it might
be thank you for the question question
representative Lind um the
concern expressed by some of the
companies was that the government May
overreach in its request in violation of
the provisions of this bill but the
companies not knowing that still
provided them with the
information they felt in that case they
should not be held liable and that's
what this provision is designed to do
um it I don't think it's particularly
significant because I don't expect New
Hampshire um Regulatory Agencies to
violate the law that's not their want
that's not the way they do business so I
don't think this is going to have much
of an impact but if somebody sues an
agency for improperly obtaining
information and it could happen um it
should be the agency that held
responsible not the company that
provided it at the agency's request and
that what this section is designed to to
deal with does it work this way the
company collects the information
legally and then the concern is are they
using that
information illegally the fact that they
have the information
you know name address phone number
Social Security whatever else they have
um they're entitled to have that
information the problem is if they use
it
illegally okay okay first of all in
today's world without this bill we're
not talking about them using anything
illegally it's basically using it for
outside their business purposes that's
really what we're trying to capture here
is that when you go when you sign up for
phone service or internet service you
provide all kinds of personal
information which has nothing to do with
anything other than the business that
wants to be able to bill you and collect
from you and that sort of thing and that
information they've legally obtained and
they control it but that's the
information that they cannot be
dispersing for money or even not for
money for any reason now if a government
entity is asking for that information
and they have the legal right to do so
and I guess even if it's not legal but
the the company doesn't know it's not
legal that's on the government not on
the
company thank you for
that anything
else representative Andrew do you have
anything
else not
really listening to everything on this
bill and when we have we're going to
have
255 I don't understand why we ar trying
to combine the two bills all into
one now that is a loaded question
representative Andress and I was
figuring you'd come up with the tough
one um representative Kirk do you want
to take that one on you don't have to
you
know I think it yes I do I think it's
worthy of an answer um
sometimes in order to understand things
you have to break them into smaller
pieces if these two were to be combined
because they deal differently they they
deal with the same subject of privacy
but they cover different entities and
they treat the different entities
differently it would be exceptionally
difficult to combine them moreover from
the purpose of the sponsors of
255 they're trying trying to get a
universal bill passed in 50 states that
is essentially what they would like to
see done at the federal level but they
can't get Congress to do if New
Hampshire were to combine the two that
would defeat their purpose and they
would very much object to that so that's
one practical problem um remember that
255 deals with only with
information it doesn't deal with good
sorry 314 Deals Only with information it
doesn't deal with
Goods um 255 deals with Goods
information but only with large
companies 314 deals with everyone
regardless of size so trying to merge
those
two I can't think of a good analogy but
it would be very difficult apples and
oranges no much much more
different thank you anything else for
our
distinguished
Witnesses I don't see anything
and now my question is do we want
to move on at this point following
representative
Anderson's lead to take a look at 255
five or or is there more that we want to
discuss first about
314 representative lint no well the only
the only thing that I would say is that
um and it I think it's it it kind of is
related to both I mean
one one thing that it seems to me that
might be an appropriate way to proceed
is sort of incrementally and
I
guess what you know what one of the
things I'm thinking as I've said before
I I tend to support 255 but I what if we
were to pass 255 but not pass
314 what that would mean is we would be
create we would be
creating privacy rights with respect not
comprehensive it would as representative
Kirk points out it it would be limited
to large large
corporations um but it would also go
beyond just the providers of services
but assuming that they are large
corporations it would not allow
individual cause of action but if we
were to pass that that it seems to
me I mean one approach that the
legislature might take is to say let's
do this which a number of other states
have done and let's see how this works
if it's not completely comprehensive
let's see how this works for you know a
year or two years or whatever and then
if there's if it makes sense to capture
smaller corporations or smaller
businesses and if it makes sense to
allow an individual cause of action um
we can deal with it after we've after
we've had that experience so that that's
that's what I was sort of gon to say
that that's an interesting approach can
you tell me me how that fits in with New
Hampshire's long and valued
tradition reflected now in the
constitution of a respect for privacy
which is
different different from or different
than different from
what we see in other
states well one you know one of the
things that I think is really an open
question
is does the does the the recently
adopted Constitutional Amendment apply
to actions other than actions by the
government normally a constitution
restrains the government it doesn't
restrain private individuals so now we
the the Supreme Court New Hampshire
Supreme Court has not construed this I
suppose they could construe it to say no
it does this does
capture individual
action I I that would be I think at
least somewhat unusual for them to
construe it that way um so
the I guess what I I guess what I'm
saying is that the the
Privacy interest created by that recent
amendment
is is probably limited only to the
government as opposed to
individual um as opposed to uh
non-governmental
entities and I guess that's why we have
three separate branches of government
and a judicial
branch to make those determinations and
you're right that there has not to my
knowledge been a case but
um
well how could I possibly question the
Judgment of a an attorney and a Supreme
Court Justice so I'm going to let that
one go for a while I may be completely
wrong I have no forecasting as to what
the you what the New Hampshire Supreme
Court would do I would like to argue
that but I would not argue it with you
right now
um is there anything else that we want
to discuss
about the first the house bill before we
go to the Senate
Bill
representative I I just wanted to
clarify my opening statement um I I was
reacting to a a separate um set of
amendments on that particular statement
that you had sent after and
misattributed it to representative um um
f and Kirk so I just wanted to clarify
that and and and the discussion that
ensued makes much more sense in terms of
where I thought the discussion was going
so thank you and sorry about that okay
um is there anyone in the audience who
we should hear from before we move on D
they
just okay this is a work session we are
we do not have uh pin cards we don't
have we're not it's not a hearing
but we are struggling to do the best
that we can
do in our role on this subcommittee and
therefore we don't want to cut ourselves
off
arbitrarily from other views that might
help inform our
decision so we're not getting into
debates or anything like that right now
but is there anyone else here who would
like to
add
substantively to what we have uh been
talking about in terms of House Bill
314 press the red button speak close to
the microphone and tell us who you are
can you hear me okay absolutely uh my
name is Andrew Kingman I represent the
state privacy and security Coalition so
we represent about 30 uh over 30
companies and six trade associations and
we work on privacy issues across all 50
states um and across uh any number of
sectors uh of the economy and where are
you based uh just North of Boston oh oh
oh up here okay so you're used to this
cold weather in it
side um
yeah and and thank you very much for for
allowing me to speak and I'm happy to
chat about 314 as as it interplays with
255 as well I think a couple points that
I just wanted to add you know I think
our preference is to would would be to
um sort of keep that divide that we've
talked about today where if we're going
to look at uh public sector uses of
personal information that 314 would be
the appropriate vehicle for that and
that if we're going to talk about
private sector uses of information that
255 would be the appropriate vehicle for
that but that to try and uh take a bill
in 314 that you know really looks to
regulate the public sector and then add
in a private right of action for
unrelated uses of personal information
um probably isn't the right approach um
couple reasons for that um we've seen in
other states where there are private
rights of action um that uh it becomes
Feeding Frenzy and while the language
may attempt to limit it to actual
damages that's not really the
calculation that's made um uh by either
side the calculation that's made is
really Discovery costs and the cost even
to um try to get a motion to dismiss off
of a lawsuit um is well into the six
figures regardless of whether you're a
small business or a large business the
other thing that I I didn't hear
discussed and and uh former Chief
Justice may have an opinion on this as
well or some uh can shed some light and
I'm not an expert but I do believe that
New Hampshire has a sovereign immunity
statute that does not allow for suits
against government entities um unless
something is intentional or there's a
failure of a duty of care and so if
we're setting up a private right of
action against both government entities
and service providers to those
government entities I think we know
where the litigation activity is going
to be directed um and so I think that's
that's another piece of our concern here
so you know I think um our sense is that
314 is an appropriate vehicle to
regulate government uses of personal
information we've offered some language
that uses some standardized definitions
across various State privacy laws like
personal uh information uh like publicly
available information and then uh have
uh would would would look to um there's
a California statute that regulates
government duties of care to minimize
the data collected from its individuals
and I think you know generally speaking
if we're talking about public sector
uses that's um a fair a fair vehicle for
that and then you know happy to chat
about um SB 255 but you know I do think
IT addresses a number of the issues uh
that folks have raised in this room
about private sector uses of of
information um I think whether it
applies only to large companies or not
is a little bit of a Up For
Debate thank you any
anybody um could you please make sure
that our uh committee researcher has
absolutely has all the contact
information for you absolutely do and if
you would like to
um submit a a summary of your comments
in
writing um happy to do so yeah we all of
us learn in different ways and that
would be be very helpful thank you any
other is there anyone else who can add
substantively to this
conversation thank you I appreciate it
let's then now let's move on
specifically to 255 do you do you want
to talk about 255 while you're sitting
there sure um you might as well yeah I
might as well um you know this is the
product not just of uh the New Hampshire
legislative process but of a number of
legislative processes that have taken
place across the country now um while
it's true that I think a lot of us uh
don't have large degrees of hope that
we'll see a federal privacy Bill we are
starting to see a de facto National
Standard emerge because we've got 11
states now that have passed a version of
this bill uh this bill 255 sort of falls
on the stronger end of that for a couple
reasons we can get into um but again
we're talking about nearly 30% of the
population uh is covered by this
framework at this point um the benefits
of this and I guess one other point
um these bills have been passed on a
bipartisan basis they've been the
product of uh the Oregon attorney
general's task force they've been the
product of um a task force in
Connecticut um and they've also been
adopted in States like Tennessee Texas
Montana Etc so this is a
bipartisan issue and and a framework
that has gotten bipartisan approval
those task forces have had not only
representatives from business but also
consumer Advocates on those task forces
that have been able to um support these
these uh bills um some of the issues
that have been brought up today around
consent and opting in um in the way that
personal data is treated so to the
representative's question about you know
repeatedly asking uh for consent um the
way that the bill is set up uh there are
three situations in which uh an indivi a
business is required to obtain consent
from uh from an individual the first is
that uh if the business wants to collect
sensitive data so data like biometric
data PR geolocation information Health
Data um thing children's data things
along those lines you have to obtain
consent from the individual the second
is that when you uh when you first start
collecting information you have to
disclose to the consumer the types of
information that you're going to be
collecting from them and if you then
start if you want to then collect
additional types of information you have
to go back and obtain consent from the
consumer as well the third situation is
that if you want to collect uh if you
are collecting the same amount of data
but you want to use it for a different
purpose than you originally told the
consumer that you were using that
purpose for you have to go back and
obtain consent from the uh from the
individual um and those last two apply
regardless of whether that's sensitive
data or
not there also could you repeat that yes
I said those last two obligations so the
idea that uh if you're purpose for
processing data changes or if the types
of data uh change that you're collecting
that you have to obtain consent from the
individual there also there's also a
data minimization provision that says
you aren't permitted to collect more
data um than is reasonable to accomplish
the purposes that you're collecting data
for um so the idea of collecting data
and then figuring out what you'll do
with it later that's not really
something that would be permitted under
under this act um there are also
significant business obligations as well
the most significant of which is the um
data protection impact assessment so
this is a documented process that EV
that a business would have to do um if
it's collecting sensitive data if it's
selling data if it's using data for
profiling um or any other type of uh
processing activity that could present
an unreasonably High heightened risk of
harm or excuse me a heightened risk of
harm to a
consumer and that requires the business
to go through a process where it
documents the risks of that processing
activity and weighs the benefits of that
and uh has to discuss ways to mitigate
that those risks that it's identified
through that processing and so you know
there are significant requirements on
businesses I think you know
certainly uh some people have the
question well then why does business
sort of give the okay to this or or why
is business able to to be okay with this
um I think a few reasons again that
interoperability the fact that it's in
so many states now businesses are
generally complying um with these types
of bills uh in those States and so you
know again we've kind of got a a
framework to work within um and then
again the the lack of a private right of
action means that businesses uh are
insulated from that privil litigation
that we know will will come in uh if
there is a private right of action
because again we've seen it in other
states um this has mechanisms to help
consumers attain redress very quickly in
the right to cure and so you know I
think um it's a very carefully balanced
framework that looks at a lot of
different inputs and outputs and tries
to achieve the right balance and again
you know so 11 states it's now gone
through 22 State Chambers you know again
countless work groups countless hearings
um and is a framework that I think you
know at the hearing uh earlier this
spring you heard many many different
stakeholders come up and say you know
this is this is sort of the right way to
go so I think our feeling is uh if we
are going to move forward with private
sector privacy legislation that HB 255
is the right
approach uh thank you our uh committee
researcher uh gave us two very valuable
documents dated the end of June and I
don't know what if anything has changed
since then one of them was the US state
privacy legislation
tracker um and then um one is comparing
255 to the Connecticut Law um I don't
know if you've seen either of of of
these but are there have there been
changes since the end of
June uh that's been happening across the
country that we should know about I
guess that's one question and the second
is did I hear you correctly when you
indicated that you thought um uh Senate
Bill
255 was more
um well how would you compare Senate
Phil
255 to the national uh the efforts to
create a national model sure um and I uh
so the the to answer your first question
about changes since June I don't
know uh when precisely that was uh
initiated but two states uh both Oregon
and Delaware um enacted and had their
governor sign the same framework uh into
law since then so that's how we got to
11 um 11 states with this framework and
then California sort of on its own own
Island uh in terms of yes no no other
state has passed that that framework
what a surprise I'm sorry I said what a
surprise I know I know um and so uh
that's so you said Oregon and what was
the other one uh Delaware okay so on
this chart we do have Oregon as active
bills but you're saying it's moved along
uh that that yeah that that passed the
legislature and signed by the governor
as as to Delaware and oh and Delaware
too okay so those okay so last last
session you know between January and
June of this year January and July seven
states passed a version of this of this
framework and then to answer your second
question about how this uh you know the
the
uh piece that this bill has um that some
of the other bills do not have uh is the
global opin or excuse me Global opt out
uh
provision this is a provision that would
have a delayed implementation date
because much of that technology does not
yet totally exist it's coming online but
this would be a browser extension or uh
some type of technology that a consumer
could download that would send a signal
to websites to opt that individual
automatically out of the sale and the
targeted advertising of their data and
so um that is a you know some states
have that provision some states do not
but H SP 255 does have that provision um
again it would I think it would go into
effect a year after the effective date
of the bill to give companies time to uh
to sort of implement and determine that
you know how they would recognize that
signal there are some issues that have
not been resolved as to as to that
technology but again that's that's the
reason for the delayed implementation
date um in terms of the small business
versus large business so the uh
representative Kirk is correct that the
bill has a threshold of 100,000
consumers in terms of uh collecting
personal data whether that is only large
businesses or not I I think is a little
bit of a matter of debate only because
you know that works out to like less
than 300 unique website visits a day to
a to a a business so if a business has
you know 300 visits a day to its website
from New Hampshire consumers that's
probably that business is probably going
to be within the scope of this bill what
300 versus 100,000 explain that to no so
just if you take a
100,000 uh data on 100,000 unique
consumers uh and just divide that by
365 right it it works out to about
270 unique consumers a day that you
might be obtaining personal information
on so again that would be a unique visit
to a website that might be a coffee shop
that does 300 uh you know transaction a
day with unique customers etc etc the
other way that this would
apply sorry I interrupted go right ahead
um I just don't understand the math but
that's all right I don't understand a
lot of math um so a b do you it seems to
me I understand what you're saying but
you're assuming then that each one of
those is someone
different yeah that's and that is is
seems to me not to be the point when you
have a state with 1.3 million people
sure um 100,000 is a very big number and
do you mean a 100,000 different people
or do you mean 27 people who are
spending a lot of time there pressing
the buttons no so it the the threshold
now is the data of 100,000 different
people so that's that's the that's the
threshold and or that's one different
people in a state with 1.3 million and
significant number of whom are either
too young or too old to be doing this
I'm in the latter category of course
um you know that's a pretty big
number yeah and and different states
have taken different approaches to that
are you know so the 100,000 number you
wouldn't be concerned if we were to take
a look at that in terms of one of the
smaller States in I think we would defer
to the instate business Community to
determine what their thoughts were on
that you see we would defer to the
legislature that passes the laws and we
would consult as we always do with the
business Community but in the end the
buck stops here of course I just meant
we wouldn't speak presume to speak for
the local businesses okay okay I
understand that then thank you very much
um so the other thing is there are some
differences between the Connecticut Law
and that seems to be a model that people
are are advocating um one example that
our researcher brought to our attention
was the definition of trade
secret
um is that something that we should be
worried about or should we yield to
Connecticut language in in order to try
to have uniformity or respect
differences so I haven't seen the
researchers memo on that generally the
definition in these bills of trade
secret is taken from the state's version
of the uniform Trade Secrets protection
act um and so I would have to double
check what the state what New
Hampshire's definition is to determine
how different it is the point of the
trade secret uh piece is to ensure that
for things like uh the ACC ACC right or
the portability right uh that consumers
have so consumers have the ability to
request all of the information that a
business has collected on them or to
provide that information in a form
whereby they can then take that to
another company right so if I'm changing
uh sell carriers and I want to ask them
to provide me the information so that I
can Port that information over to
another carrier the point of the trade
secret protections there are to make
sure that businesses aren't put in the
position of saying do we have to provide
proprietary information um or violate
the law by not providing all of the
information back to the consumer so
that's the function of the trade secret
piece here um and trade secrets are
typically in state law a term of art so
it's not something that businesses can
just decide uh you know oh well this is
a trade secret or this trade secret it's
it's generally a term of art I'm not an
IP lawyer so I've now said all of the
things that I know about uh Trade
Secrets but um that's the intent of that
of that protection there is to protect
the proprietary information um that a
business would not generally be required
to provide anyway we understand the
value of uniformity and and the help
that we could get to push this along so
that maybe at some point in the
foreseeable future future the federal
government would step up to the plate on
this um but by the same token this is a
state that Prides itself on its
individuality and on places where it
differs yes I mean for example you know
the
uniform a lot of the uniform laws take a
long time before we're willing to sign
on in this state sure because of among
other things we do respect
privacy and and we always have or
historically we always have as a state
um but we don't want to arbitrarily
differ um just for the sake of differing
and that's why I'm trying to you know to
see what in the language of um sure of
255 um could be improved or not I I
think our sense um is that
you know this is substantially similar
to Connecticut um I would also note in
the you know I I understand New
Hampshire's uh you know deep roots of
individuality and that it may not look
to what Oregon or Montana or Texas is
doing and find a pattern there but I
would also note that in addition to
Connecticut um you know Maine is
considering a version of this framework
Rhode Island is very getting very close
to moving forward with a version of this
framework and I do think that there's so
many consumers and businesses who work
within the New England region that
Regional alignment um you know is
important and you know should be uh you
know sort of at the top of our thinking
around what what would work we have
people who you know travel in between
states every day and we have businesses
who work within the region so their
ability to have common expectations
about what works and what doesn't work I
think um makes a lot of sense for for
New Hampshire I think one of the reasons
that you heard um so much support for
this bill in the spring um is that you
know everyone felt like okay we're at a
we're at a place where we can move
forward with this and you know it's
moved through the Senate and sort of
last stop here before the house floor um
and just trying to you know get it over
that that hump there could I ask one one
other question I I don't want to
misremember
um did I understand you when you began
by talking about the house bill and then
we've now gone to the Senate bill that
you recognized the acknowledge the
differences between the two and the
value of each of those bills sure rather
than seeing one as a substitute for
another correct I think they're
addressing two different pieces that
that HB 314 would would primarily
address public sector uses of personal
information sp sp 255 certainly is
private sector uses of information I did
what a chair should not do I immediately
began asking you questions and did not
look to my colleagues who probably have
much better questions I'm very sorry I
apologize for
that represent V your light is on is
that just yeah I had a question I want
to go back to um the number
um of I think um if uh you had mentioned
100,000 are any of the other states that
have passed this into legislation um
have they decreased the number to maybe
50,000 35,000 25,000 one um
Delaware uh I
believe I've got to do this off the top
of my head so I believe
Delaware is 50,000 it maybe 35,000
um
and just trying
to go across the different
states yeah yeah so I'm sorry what was
that Montana I believe is
50,000 um and then uh I believe it was
Tennessee that actually raised it uh to
one to 175,000 so that is a number that
different states have moved depending
on whether their feeling is they want
every you know they want more businesses
to be included or they only want the
largest businesses to be included thank
you for that um yes representative yeah
just just one clarification it's kind of
a followup on on the question I think
that you asked about the the interplay
between the two bills um am I right in
understanding that your thought the your
thought is that the the need for both
bills stems from the idea idea that 314
the previous bill that we talked about
would be solely focused on government
entities um because I believe the
conversation had kind of gone the
opposite direction of that and I just
wanted to understand it may have been
your your version that I had looked at
or I confused yeah the language that
we'll make sure the the uh this
committee gets would a would uh add a
definition of service provider into
hb314 to make sure that um
the that bill deals with but
appropriately segregates
responsibilities for the government
agencies which are in that situation the
consumer facing entity um the one that
the consumer is dealing with and the one
that would be collecting information
directly from the consumer and then the
service provider which similar to SP 255
is the business that the government
entity would have engaged to do
particular um processes on their their
behalf um that might be collecting
information on the government entities's
behalf it might be analyzing information
on their behalf or collating information
somehow but um you know our point you
know the the point that I just wanted to
make is that if if we add a private
right of action that applies to those
service providers who are performing
tasks at the direction of the government
entities that it will be those service
providers and not the entity itself
who's you know coming up with what they
want to do with the information Etc um
that will end up bearing the brunt of
the litigation um both because that's
where the financial resources will be
and because I think and again I could be
wrong but I believe that there's
signific some significant sovereign
immunity issues about whether
individuals can sue the state for
anything other than an intentional tort
or a failure of a of a duty of care
okay yeah I
think Divine looks a little
troubled what about representative Devon
just quickly so you're what you guys are
talking about I just want to get this
straight on 314 adding like Goods
because goods and goods and services
isn't a part
of House Bill 314 yeah our Goods part is
our edits would just would not
distinguish between goods and services
it would just cover personal
information um which would be any
information linked or reasonably
linkable to a consumer so anything that
could even be reasonably linked to a
consumer would count as personal
information and it would it would just
establish that business that the
government has a duty to minimize the
collection of that in a couple different
circumstances again that you know that's
patterned after a lot that that
California had has had for some time and
we think seems to get at the intent of
what hb314 was was sort of looking for
okay I just wanted to add to that just
so I'm thinking right about certain
types of businesses so say Amazon where
they sell Goods they would be included
in that kind of it it would cover any
entity that contracts with the state
with the state okay but it would cover
them in their capacity as a State
Contractor right
okay can can I also
sorry just sort of a followup on my
previous I I just wanted to clarify
because I from our previous discussion
in 314 it was kind of my understanding
that the point of it was to broaden it
beyond the
government um and I guess this question
is to our other members of the committee
was I miss understanding that or or or
was or or was it sort of that 314 should
focus on government entities
representative Blinn wants to comment I
think yeah no I think in answer to your
question my my proposed amendment to 314
would limit it to the government um
representative F and rep and former
representative Kirk's Amendment would
would not do that it would be it would
cover um the the private sector
also I believe the point of
Representative F's
proposal is the private sector and not
the government in that among other
things in this
state we have a high level of confidence
in the ability of the
government to behave um
appropriately and so we want to
encourage everyone to follow that model
and that means we want to focus sure on
private and I think our sense is if
we're going to talk about the private
sector that sp sp 255 would be a much
more comprehensive and sort of balanced
approach there than than hb314 in that
case Okay anything
else anything else okay um thank you
very much if you would give us you know
make sure our research has the
information that we need and she will
make sure it gets to us um is there
anyone else here who would like to add
to this discussion yes
sir press the microphone so the red
buttons on and speak quite closely to it
because um it's not just the people in
this room this is all being recorded and
people will be listening aply very good
thank you to the chair um my name is
David Miller uh you may but probably
don't remember me from could you speak
into the M please oh um I was here for
the hearing earlier this year in the
capacity of an individual employed in
privacy and security engineering as a
private citizen but I'm now a resident
of the state so I come before you not as
a lobbyist but as someone hopefully
bringing both some professional
experience and as a
constituent by the way almost all the
lobbyists in this room are also
constituents I just want you to
excellent very good to
hear um I have a few uh primary points
to bring up and I thank the chair and
several other members of the committee
for uh being particularly concerned with
the threshold of 100,000 persons uh in
the
bill the history of the state
bills in the US is roughly as follows um
a real estate agent in San
Francisco parlayed with some
brinksmanship with Facebook lawyers uh
and instead of a referendum got CCPA
passed no bill since has been a copycat
of the California bill in instead there
are roughly two lineages of where the
texts come
from there's the Virginia bill which was
the second one to pass and had a
stronger uh right to opt in to the
collection of sensitive information so
it included data minimization more
similarly to say Canada and the EU and
then there was adpa which was a federal
bill that uh Nancy Pelosi defeated
because it would have preempted uh some
stronger Provisions in the California
bill this week and next week there are
hearings in three states in New England
about bills similar to
s255 Maine actually has two bills being
considered LD 1977 and LD
1973 1973 which was mentioned by one of
the prior speakers uh is actually based
on the Virginia template just like ours
is but LD 1977 is based on ad
PPA
Massachusetts is having hearings next
week on a bill based on
adpa and of course we have this one
here now different states have taken
different approaches to the threshold
that they have chosen it's true that
Tennessee increased the number to
175,000 but Tennessee has a population
of 6.9
million Delaware so far is the state
Delaware and Montana are the states with
the most similar populations to New
Hampshire sure that have passed uh bills
like this and uh as mentioned by the
prior speaker Delaware has chosen a
threshold of
35,000 and Montana has chosen a
50,000 New Hampshire has a population
pyramid that skews uh towards people
under 18 for whom there are some
existing Protections in federal law um
although perhaps inadequate um and to
the elderly there are a lot of young
people who move to the rest of the
country and return to New Hampshire
later because of that population
skew a threshold of
100,000 would
exclude um let's say phone apps or tech
companies or any data collector and
processor from
consideration whose Target demographic
is a minority of any kind and it
shouldn't be a partisan issue because
that could be people of color who
represent a small minority of the state
it could be people with an alternate
sexual
orientation um where the protection of
the data is quite important but even if
sensitive data were collected it
wouldn't matter because 100,000
threshold as 5% of one gender and
usually only people in a certain age
demographic would quickly fall below the
threshold or it could be a religious
community or people of a particular
uh political persuasion and consequently
I would recommend lowering the threshold
to something similar to the Delaware
Montana
number another point I'd like to bring
up is the
following other than redefining individ
uh oh so sorry one more point about the
numbers the numbers in ADP were Federal
the 100,000 Criterion remember comes
vaguely from the California bill which
was about a much much larger State now
the threshold of a couple hundred
thousand in
adpa makes sense for a federal Bill and
Maine has done something interesting the
bill hasn't passed yet the hearings are
next week but Maine has adopted adpa and
not redefined the term individuals or
consumers to meet only residents of the
state the bills that have passed so far
have all done that Massachusetts
actually says resident or person
physically present in
Massachusetts possibly because they're
trying to protect persons who come from
other states in order to receive
abortion
care
but most of the
states require that the person is
somehow connected to the state and so
does
s255 Maine doesn't and they keep the
200,000 threshold so there's various
things that you can do with
s255 to make the threshold make sense
but the current one is too big and I
recommend looking at the other states
for inspiration I'll be happy to provide
written testimony to assist with that
with links to the relevant bills to your
researcher the other thing is that it
might be interesting to look at
mechanisms that aren't uh arbitrary uh
private right of action for all the
provisions of the
um because of course that could burden
the business Community um but to look at
things like injunctive relief or private
right of action preemptable by the
Attorney
General only for certain clearly
articulated violations of the Privacy
rights of individuals such as a
reportable data breach of course there's
a lot of things to be determined about
how the law will be interpreted that
would make a general right of private
action
likely raise the eye the business
Community but I would encourage the
committee to
consider other limited ways for
consumers to exercise their rights
especially if a significant number of
New Hampshire residents are impacted by
a
violation um data minimization is a
common feature of uh Stronger data
privacy laws in our largest trading
partners including ENC counted in the
European
Union and um it's arguable that uh the
Virginia and Connecticut template on
which nh25 is based uh introduces data
minimization only for the most sensitive
data and that these protections could be
made stronger that being said that would
be a major change to the bill so I won't
go off on it too long and there's one
very small additional recommendation I
would make there is an exemption in this
text that does not exist in some of the
other state laws with exactly the same
wording and that is the exemption
related to FC the last time that Fally
the Federal Credit Reporting Act of
1974 a lot of brokering of data in this
country comes from the fact that other
than now the Social Security
Administration uh We've chosen as a
country to actually have the private
sector handle the data base of our
population many countries have
population registers the United States
has the credit
bureaus and a lot of information is
exchange for the purposes of
establishing creditworthiness now
subsequent to the civil rights movement
and also to the church committee
investigation and realizations about the
FBI and its stance on anti-war
protesters in the 60s the last time that
Federal Congress considered a slew of
privacy legislation that is still in
effect was in the early 7s and the
Federal Credit Reporting Act is one of
the pieces of legislation that came out
of
that but the exemption in
s255 for federal Credit Reporting Act
doesn't say that you are Exempted from
coverage if you are supplying the data
directly to a credit bureau it can be
interpreted and I'm not the lawyer it
can be interpreted as meaning that if
any data that you provide to an external
that you transfer to an external entity
is used for FC related purposes then all
of your activities fall out of coverage
of the law and I would recommend that a
word like primarily or principally or
significantly or some clearer standard
be introduced to that Clause to ensure
that it is not an
invitation for uh companies to get out
of coverage of the law wholesale by
transferring token amounts of
information to uh secondary FC related
entities thank you thank you very much
any
questions thank you for that and would
you please again make sure that our
researcher um knows how to get in touch
with you and if you were going to submit
anything in writing that you do that
pretty soon great okay is there anyone
else
chair and members of the subcommittee
thanks for allowing me to speak today um
I'm not gonna go very long my name is my
name is Matthew Schwarz I'm a policy
Analyst at Consumer
Reports um I'm not GNA go very long
David and I have been working together
and he covered a lot of the the same
points that I was going to bring up uh
and I believe representative tur has um
some points that cover
uh uh uh those issues so I'm going to
just let maybe him bring those up and
and available for for any questions
about that so you don't have anything
else to say now um we're very glad
you're here welcome to the Hampshire
yeah thank you thank you make sure you
see the leaves
changing um maybe I'll go a little bit
off script and and just say you know
David brought up the fcra exemption I
have similar concerns about about the
entity level exemptions for please use
um the English language uh I have
concerns about the exemptions for for
financial institutions under the gram
leech blly act so this bill as it's
drafted says that if uh the the the
financial institution has any data
that's covered by glba Graham leech Bly
than the entire uh institutions Exempted
but we're quickly kind of moving into a
world where tech companies could be
cover covered by Gram Le flyy and these
are the the very companies that we you
know have the data abuses that we're
we're worried about here I'd be
concerned that if you know a small part
of that business is covered by grle
biley then we're just gonna exempt the
entire business and that's that's pretty
problematic now it is that in the
original bill or is that in an amendment
that's been proposed that's in the
original
bill um oh okay so I
can quickly navigate to the section I'm
sure you can find it more quickly than
I yeah so that's in 507 H3 the
exclusions i
e
okay okay thank
you right and thank you and there's a
similar exemption
for uh uh companies that are covered
under Hippa so medical providers
hospitals insurance companies if you
have any information that's covered by
hippo the entire entity is Exempted um
again Amazon Facebook
Apple all moving to provide you know
health care products uh and if they
eventually come under you know coverage
of HIPPA I'd be concerned that you know
the entire company would then then be
Exempted from this bill
um and so I would argue that at the very
least we should be only exempting them
to the extent that they're covered by
these these other laws and in areas
where they're or not uh they should
still be subject to S SP
255 thank you very much for that any
questions
comments in general I will say that that
my top three concerns are the threshold
the enforcement uh and the data
minimization but we've talked about all
of that already thank
you thank you go on the
bike we have
gotten it works want get thing we canel
but we haven't gotten a final word yet
about what is
AG I think if it's not prob will go but
U okay we have't have and okay I me my
my
it's you know but I don't know that all
right
um uh I want to thank all of you for
being here uh today um and
helping the committee deal with two
important but very complicated
bills what I would like to suggest
um provisionally this might have to be
changed for other reasons but what I
would like to suggest
provisionally is that we
reconvene this
subcommittee um on Tuesday the
24th of of um October that might have to
be changed um but so pencil it in for
those of us who write in pencil and
don't just put it into an electronic
Gizmo
um and we will confirm shortly and what
I would like to do on the 24th which
might not be possible is to ask that we
have before
us a proposed proposed amendments on the
two
bills separate amendments separate bills
um
that would make it possible for the
committee perhaps to actually reach a
point of recommendation where we could
say to the full committee we are
recommending Amendment
X for 314 and Amendment
y for
255 and then um it would come those
would come to the full committee for
discussion on the 8th of
November um the reason I'm suggesting
the 24th is that gives us two weeks to
um really think about what the amendment
what amendment we would like to have and
it gives us another two weeks before we
go to the
full committee so that we're not rushing
this we're not we're not meeting at 9
o'clock in the
morning to then vote on something at 10
o'clock in the morning does that make
sense to everybody yes okay so I will
thank everyone for being here um I will
adjourn this session and we confirm as
soon as possible that we will be meeting
again as a subcommittee
on the
24th at
10:00
okay thank you
again